guys this episode's gonna be late and
let's
not point fingers but we all know whose
fault it is
hmm hmm oh someone is pointing fingers
usually we like to get these out on
friday i don't know when this is coming
out but
it means i'm done editing it but it's
not friday so we're sorry about that
well i i also curse god and usually you
like to take weekends off right pills
what's that you usually like to take
weekends off pills that's why you like
to edit on fridays and then
and then be done for the weekend i do
take saturdays off i'm not able to take
weekends off
yeah i usually take sunday off saturday
is also
typically what i call a hungover work
day so it's usually where i prepare my
lectures for the week
all right all right we all take a chill
pill
and just get to moral
argumentation moral reasoning for there
is nothing
either good or bad but thinking makes it
so and to me
denmark is a prison oh yeah little
hamlet there
to get us started beautiful well i feel
like we're going to split along
lib lines again because we have to talk
about morality which is
who picked this topic
i think matt first suggested it right i
don't think so no
that sounds like i actually remember
saying i didn't want to talk about meta
ethics
oh no this was because matt posted on
twitter
remarks that marx was making a moral
argument and that was my first
twitter i said he had implicit moral
arguments there's a difference
while an implicit argument is that an
argument or is it just a bad argument
it's a bad argument which is why i said
it should be explicated if the premise
is implied then it's not actually a
premise
so let's let's let's maybe that's a good
place to start why don't we like so
let's get back to that original tweet
matt what was what's
what's your claim about marx wait first
let me roll the music
[Music]
okay
[Music]
okay it's been rolled sweet music
insert here insert here
it's that i was i expressed my
frustration at the fact that some
critical theorists
tend to be skeptical uh of any kind of
argument that's framed as a moral
argument
right uh they tend to either like to
engage in what's broadly called crash
trashing which is
broadly critical activity uh or they
think that you know the only kind of
argument that you should make is
description how would you define a moral
argument just to get us started so like
what is it that you think they're
they're avoiding well moral
like a moral judgment uh just involves
why are you talking about us like we're
not here
i don't well i just thought i just
thought that we would i would get us
started we'd we define our terms like a
good analytic philosophy for what
ew i actually don't know what side uh
eric's on on this debate oh boy
i hope he's on my side because he has
read nietzsche unlike the libs
so but let's but but i think it's
important to say like so what is what
would be like a moral judgment or a
moral claim like to say something is
like that some state of affairs is like
good or not good or condemnable yeah i
think it's just an evaluative judgment
about what one ought to do
right uh in the kind of human sense
right and
what one ought to do uh is obviously
contentious and it really depends upon
the moral theory
that you think is correct right whether
you're a consequentialist a virtue
ethicist or a deontologist
what makes that a human question he said
there is no art
well no he said that all questions are
different than his questions
so that we know we're talking about that
is the
it's called the naturalist fallacy right
or the human guillotine
i prefer yeah i think that one's more
yeah i mean it's there's a common
refrain in all this is that you can't
reason
to what we ought to do from what is you
can't reason ought from
is that's a common refrain in this
which i'm not trained in the analytic
tradition so i don't know but i did
watch the good place when she explained
that there are three kinds of ethics
there's aristotelian virtue ethics
there's
deontology which is the duty stuff and
then there's consequentialism
those are the three great branches some
people like to add nihilism as a fourth
which is more like a lack of
morality lack of belief in the objective
reality of any kind of moral system
that's nihilism just being modest yeah
sorry just to be modest and
multicultural people have pointed out
that these three traditions do map on to
non-european traditions as well so for
instance there's a very rich field of
confucian uh virtue ethics right now
uh focusing on ren rather than
eudaimonia
then there's also you know other
deontological traditions that you can
see
people have pointed out that you know
for instance various forms of sunni
islam
tends to take a very rule-oriented form
pretty consistent with deontology
and then there's also things like
chinese legalism that maps on to various
kinds of consequentialism
right so whether or not these categories
are
universally applicable you know virtue
ethics consequentialism deontology
uh it does seem that a lot of moral
systems at least seem to take on
elements of these forms there's also
feminist ethics which i think is uh
you could fit it into consequentialism
yeah although it tends to be
generally critical of universalist
ethics
well there's there's lots of different
kinds of of of feminism but yeah i mean
potentially i think uh i was gonna say
uh to like eric's
definition of sort of the the nihilism
is maybe the fourth branch and i wonder
if
that's what falls into uh maybe what you
were pointing at matt with like sort of
the more critical because i think like
do you think the critical approaches
like map on to nihilism somehow because
in their refusal to actually like state
a moral claim
i don't personally think they do right i
mean if you look at most forms of
critical theory
the general focus tends to be on one of
two things right emancipation or
equality or emancipation and equality
as it is called right and i completely
endorse
you know these aspirations since i
believe in liberty and equality
but it is worth noting that prioritizing
though those
does involve a kind of normative
evaluation right
we could just as easily say that wow
people shouldn't be free and people
shouldn't be equal and we shouldn't have
democracy and everyone should be a slave
right i would disagree with that moral
judgment but it is
uh you know a legitimate moral claim to
make
but that's not the moral claim that you
make from the perspective of critical
theory
well that that i know but what i'm
saying is usually implicit within
various forms of critical theory and
this relates back to the canteen idea
of critique right from which this all
originated uh is this notion that what
we should prioritize is
various kinds of freedom or emancipation
or even radical emancipation to use my
preferred words
and then this is usually associated with
some notion that emancipation
needs to take the form uh a team needs
to take an egalitarian form right that
somebody's voice isn't being heard or
institutions are representing someone
right some difference
is not being right but the reason for
that is not a moral argument
from uh critical theory perspective here
i'll offer my account but let me just
say something really quickly can i just
say one thing really quickly because i
think it's important to clarify what i
think the
matt's matt and probably my position is
too is that like i think the claim is
more
that actually underlying the cr the
critical traditions and what gets to his
original tweet is
that there's actually a crypto
normativity here yeah so it's not so
much that they're actually making a
moral claim it's that they actually are
depending on one but are unwilling to
say it
so therefore they're crypto normative
not actually holding to their yeah
and i think nietzsche would say the same
thing actually okay no that's not true
yes it would if if they do that's
incidental the argument actually is
an argument for self-interest that's
saying if you're a
a parole then you don't need to accept
the state of affairs because there are
more pearls
than bougies that's not a moral argument
that's a claim to self-interest that
says you can change the world
so that it better reflects your will
rather than the will of the ruling class
okay but if that's an if that is an
injunction right if that's just a
descriptive statement like you can
change the world
then there would really be no point in
engaging in critical theory
generally speaking right i mean the kind
of expectation is that
going back to kant once you recognize
that you are capable of changing the
world you will change the world and
that's a beneficial thing
right yeah but otherwise you know you
end up with somebody who's just saying
like well it's theoretically the pros
could revolt but that's not a good thing
and we shouldn't do it
in which case you might ask why the hell
would you write this book in the first
place this is what i'm saying there's
not a moral
premise i think generally leftist people
do are leftist because of some sympathy
or empathy or whatever the right
word is because they think that a better
world for them
is also a better world for most people
but the argument
for a leftist politic or a libertary
politic is not that everyone should be
equal
it's that it's going to be better for
the people that are
now being downtrodden if they were to
change the world that's not a
moral there's no moral premise that is
absolutely more a claim it's a claim
that
what we should do is try to better those
who aren't benefiting from the system
right now
but that's a the argument is for power
it's not it's about it's about power but
it's also about the importance of
actually redistributing power relations
or reorganizing power relations that
those who have no power right now
will have it in the future right that's
absolutely it's first and foremost a
descriptive
enterprise not a prescriptive enterprise
right to describe
capitalism and capitalism has a certain
inherent
morality capitalism itself as a mode of
production
and as something that produces you know
relations of production and ideological
things
it has a certain way of discriminating
between
right and wrong and today we're always
faced with the idea that
what is right is to encourage
say policies that encourage economic
growth
that encourage self-interest that
de-emphasize government intervention
like capitalism
certain versions of it have these sort
of moral principles
built into it and part of critical
theory
is and the reaction i heard you guys
talking about universalism
before we started recording and
you know it's it's not a popular
position anymore but it is there
that morality is relative it's
culturally relative
it's historically relative there are no
the reason that
like i'm a believer in a limited form of
universality too
but i also believe that our sense of
right and wrong
radically changes from even from one
generation to the next never mind one
mode of production to the next
i think it's worth untangling because it
seems like pills is saying
that like it's actually an injunction
about like that people
will follow their self-interest or if
they're if they become aware if they get
the proper information about their class
position
is it that they should because if you're
saying that these people should follow
their self-interest that's a moral claim
that's a normative claim about should
but then is there just like more of a
causal almost
like a causal claim that once people
realize their self-interest they will
act in a certain way because like that's
the only way to make it a purely
descriptive statement is if you're just
saying
well i take that to be the marxist
position certainly that there's a
contradiction
between what's being offered and between
how the world is
so we just have to naturally expect that
the world will change
to resolve that contradiction so i think
it is descriptive not prescriptive
okay so i'd like to be able to see i
mean very carefully avoid saying
should follow yourself no i i don't
think that is saying
he's saying people will that's how it
has happened and will continue to happen
okay okay but okay this is where it
becomes problematic in a number of
different ways right
you're absolutely right that marx
presents himself in a certain sense as
being
purely a descript offering a descriptive
account of how it is that
emerging capitalist society operates
right and then there's this teleological
vision of history of where at the end
communism is going to arrive human
beings subconsciously create their own
history for the first time
and this is inevitably going to happen
and we should just accept it right
now as it goes that can be just cast in
purely descriptive terms
but it's not ps in purely descriptive
terms because marx tends to argue that
this is going to be
a beneficial development right and
making that kind of evaluation is
fundamentally normative
and if you want i can give a good
counter example uh
the uh libertarian economist arthur
schuppenter
who wrote a very good book called
capitalism democracy
a populism socialism and democracy sorry
i actually agreed with marx he said that
i believe socialism is inevitably going
to come
he's absolutely right about this
dialectic but this is going to be a
catastrophe
right it's going to mean the end of all
innovation it's something we should
really not look forward to
uh and that's also a moral claim right
so whether or not you read this
descriptive story that marx is
uh giving and you agree with them that
this is something we should
applaud or whether you agree with
superhero and you think this is
something we should be repelled by
you have to make moral judgments about i
don't know i think what you're con
you're you're putting two things
together here you're saying like that
guy would say
that this is going to lead to this and
then there's a whole other moral claim
built into that saying
that this would be bad because that's
what it is that's
remarkable moral claim is separate from
the this will happen claim
to this would be bad claim so he's not
like that's not a moral argument in
itself there's
maybe if he believes it's a bad thing
he's making an implicit value judgment
but that's not a moral argument if i say
if i throw this ball at this window this
window will break
whether or not i think it's a bad thing
to vandalize somebody's property i'm not
making a [ __ ] moral claim there i'm
just saying what
would happen and the guy's probably
wrong because most
critics of marx who take a conservative
direction are just okay we're gonna have
to bring in the rules of debate here
if people keep interrupting each other
you should
not interrupt but sorry matt go ahead
yeah okay i'll shout not this is the
point that i'm trying to make right if
you read marx's work carefully
it's very clear that he's evaluating
this as a beneficent development
right in a very hegelian fashion because
ultimately the story of history is the
story of human emancipation and
rival itself consciousness and this
should all be applauded as
a positive development right the point
that they're trying to get at with
stupid towers that you're exactly right
you know
you can tell the same descriptive story
about capitalism right that
it's inevitably going to be extremely
productive for a while then it's going
to fall
and decline but whether or not you see
that as a positive or a negative thing
is really dependent upon your normative
evaluation but those are two separate
debate those are two separate arguments
being made then
okay yeah but yeah but let me finish
follow your own rules okay
uh because if you read you know his kind
of accounts and particularly
okay let me finish my point you know and
if you read this kind of arguments for
instance about how it is that communism
is going to be as he puts it in the
manner
sorry in the capital a far higher form
of society
right talking about a higher form of
society is ultimately a moral judgment
right it's something that's better it's
something that's beneficial
it's buttressed by a moral judgment it's
not in itself a moral judgment
i think it's absolutely yeah well i
think that you know when somebody writes
a manifesto you can assume that they are
valuing the things they're saying in a
positive way
but they're not making necessarily moral
claims
you can make moral claims to back things
up like capitalism
is the right way to live because it's
good to follow your self-interest and
that's how democracies work if everybody
represents
themselves in a democracy then it'll
function correctly
and functioning correctly is good the
moral you have to separate the moral
argument from
these claims and predictions and will
bees and woodbees yeah i think you can
actually built in there but they're like
buttresses on a cathedral
that's not the structure itself they're
just holding it up a little bit
okay but that's exactly what i'm saying
i absolutely agree that marx is making
telling a descriptive story here that's
buttressed by these kind of normative
claims
but but just by the claim that
capitalism is gonna
undergo increasing exploitation of the
working class
and that's the bad thing yeah well i
think there's a huge problem there since
there are normative
uh judgments baked into his account of
labor also but we'll put that aside for
now
i think you know that i would much
rather he actually be he was explicit
about the kind of normative evaluations
that you say serve as a buttress
so we could actually deliberate upon
them and have some clarity on them
because that's not the way things are uh
as the text stands
right now right uh it's rather confusing
where it is that he's making normative
evaluations and when he's just telling a
story
and i would rather be there be some
methodological clarity on these points
because i actually agree with him about
both his uh moral claim
and about a lot of his descriptive
claims right i just want some
to use victor's preferred term
analytical clarity on these issues i
like analytical clarity
i don't find those two things confusing
at all because it's easy to separate
in my mind but victor what do you think
well you can you can separate those
things but i think like the real
objection here
is you know there's a we're debating
here like what what was
what's actually in the text of marx but
then there's like a separate question
about like how has critical theory been
taken up since marx
and i think i mean it is debatable i've
been teaching marks recently uh to
in my tutorial and like you know
obviously there's a difference between
early and late marks i think early marks
clearly has
seems much more normative and is making
a lot of value judgments about like
human
human self actualization and well-being
and
um but in any case but like i think what
really i'm interested in is
the way like the critical attitude in
theory the way it's taken up to sort of
condemn certain states of affairs
um as being somehow deleterious to
something some human
that like that is just to pretend that
that's not filled with normative content
uh just seems ridiculous to me like like
that's clearly
so steeped in claims about certain
states of affairs being better than
others
but then there's a refusal to like
unpack what that means because then
you're gonna end up being some
analytical lib or something and it's
like no no like
there's a there's a value to like
unpacking what those what those claims
what are we what's what's behind those
moral like judgments
and and evaluations of the states of
affairs being good or bad and like i
think that's a worthwhile project
yeah and i'll give you an example from
vuco right just to ship gears a little
bit right
uh if you just want to take vaca as a
descriptive social scientist
i could read discipline and punish and
say that this is a very interesting
account of society and i might even make
a moral judgment if i was psychotic
that this sounds great this is the kind
of society that we should have
you know what i mean we should have a
disciplinary society the fact that you
know the book is clearly
a critique of this implies that we
shouldn't be satisfied with this state
of affairs or that there's something
normatively wrong with the emergence of
a disciplinary society
and that's where the book gets some of
its power from and i would much rather
that the normative basis of this
critique be explicated as it ultimately
was near the end of his life
where he starts talking about this
nietzschean ethics of self-creation that
he tends to prefer
rather than it just being baked in uh
to the analysis or serving as a buttress
as eric would say
right just because i think things become
clearer then and we can actually
understand
why it is that we should dislike this
society not just get a very rich and
interesting descriptive account of how
it is that the society works
i mean i have two ways of talking about
this first of all something like like
when you talk about normative claims
right when people make normative claims
part of the critical theory tradition
is really focused on debunking like what
normativity is and
what it means and so when you have like
marx talks about the difference between
use value
and exchange value right like the use
value is natural it's part of the
material
of the commodity and the exchange value
obtains over and above it exchange value
is purely metaphysical
and what darida points out is actually
use value is just
as metaphysical he's pointing out the
ways
that through normativity through these
ideas about
what we think the way the world just is
is actually how
metaphysical claims sneak into our
reasoning and so when marx just puts
this sort of simple
value on the use value of a product
he's actually allowing normative claims
metaphysical claims to sneak into his
work
uncritical unexamined so that's why
there's so much suspicion
that i mean that's one example of why
there's so much suspicion about
normative claims and the second thing
let me just this one's quicker
is that normativity goes way beyond
ethics you're talking about normativity
like it's
all about morality but normativity
is also built into science normativity
is built into aesthetics
normativity is built into logic
normativity is built into everything
right
like aesthetics what is good and what is
bad
what kinds of art should we make what
kinds of art shouldn't we make logic
how to reason how we should reason how
we shouldn't reason science
what is the best method how should we
proceed
about investigating our claims we make
about the world how do we
experiment in order to confirm that our
beliefs are
true or false normativity is in
everything it's not limited to morality
it's not some secret thing that
critical theorists are denying exist or
aren't in their work
it's everywhere and usually we just say
it's metaphysical because we're trying
to be critical of it we're saying
metaphysical claims about the way the
world really is is actually ideology and
you have to be careful
when you're making these sorts of
arguments so those are the two things
right
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'm not gonna make a
long-winded point but the one
reason that i can see on its face is the
most obvious that a critical theorist
would not want to use
morally normative claims
would be that uh reorganization
of power is bad for the powerful
so they're not going to agree with your
normative argument
so they're not going to make claims that
can be just disputed but by
someone else saying no i don't want that
they're going to say
we can find liberation for more people
by you know overthrowing the ruling
class or whatever the
whatever the critical theory happens to
be in the foucault case it would you
know it would be strategic in foucault's
case as well
to not make normative value judgments
okay but like first off i want to say i
completely agree with everything that
eric said
the reason i'm focusing on morality is
that and actually i think that speaks to
all the point that we're making is that
that's just one kind of normative
judgment that's baked in uh to a lot of
these apparently descriptive accounts
uh if you really want to be far more
robust about it there's all kinds of
other ways that we can conceive of
normativity that's also
typically baked into what seemed like
purely descriptive accounts
uh and that we could also unpack in a
deridian fashion right
and one of the reasons i like somebody
like darida at least in this point is
he was actually cognizant enough about
this to actually make clear
what a lot of his own uh ethical and
normative preferences were particularly
in the late period right so if anything
he's engaging in the kind of critical
theorizing i like where at the end he's
at least saying look i have a
perspective
this is what i think we should do in a
number of different fields
and i'm going to be transparent about
that at least as transparent as derek
ever gets right and the other thing i
want to say is that i think one of the
reasons why critical theorists
don't try to make normative claims
explicitly
is in part because they think that this
is going to wind up becoming
ideologically over determined and
captured by the powerful
and they also tend to have this
democratic sense that it's not for me to
kind of lay out a blueprint for you
uh this should be determined by those
who liberate themselves from power using
my description as a guide
and then they'll conceive of and
construct new forms of life on that
basis
right uh but it's worth noting that even
the word you use is liberation
right uh liberation is very much a kind
of moral notion right that it's
important to be liberated
right that we want is liberated
subjectivities
right and what frustrates me sometimes
about this work is
unlike darada who at least was open
about this many of the people don't go
that far
and actually explain why it is we should
prioritize something like liberation
right it's just almost taken for granted
that liberation is a good thing
but you're looking for a universalist
claim in that sense then because like
why we should do something
well because maybe maybe because it's
relevant right now
maybe 50 years ago we shouldn't have
done that but now
it's something that we should do no i
would actually say that the thing about
critical theory is
it's very fundamentally universalistic
at its very core because most critical
theorists
tend to implicitly regard liberation as
a good thing or a gale belt
right and there's a long tradition of
this going back to hegel and can
right and one of the reasons why i would
actually like that to be made explicit
because then we can have a conversation
about it and actually try to explain
why it is that we think liberty and
equality are important because it's not
obvious that they are
right uh if i really wanted to be fully
nietzschean i could sit there and say
that
why should we care about liberty right
why should we can i add something next
yeah go ahead if it's directly on this
point it's directly on this point okay
because i just want to add something to
what matt said which is i think another
part of it
which is like where i i've become sort
of fixated lately on this idea of
a critical theorist being
crypto-normativist is because i think to
me like
the the issue that i'm seeing is i think
there's really an attachment
in the critical theory tradition an
attachment to to
almost being culturally defined by their
opposition to
some sort of like like i don't know if
western or like rationalist or like
thickly metaphysical
commitments like i think there's a
cultural attachment to being opposed to
that
thickly metaphysical sounds like a dildo
i have to say
stay on track stay on track do you shop
for dildos often that have like
multi-syllabic
titles yeah what the hell are you
talking about
that kind of came out of left field bro
i don't know what's going on there he's
probably thinking of he's looking at a
browser window
all right well what i'm trying to say
here is that i think that in the
critical theory tradition
there's a there's a there's a cultural
attachment right to
being opposed to um western rationalism
or like kind of this universalistic
language so i guess like the thing that
i'm really
interested in pointing to is like is
there actually good reason for that
anymore like i'm not
i don't feel like i'm less convinced by
the reasons for that and i guess i kind
of want to point out and like maybe
kind of provoke people to think like is
this really more of just like a cultural
like almost rhetorical thing because i
agree with matt that i actually think
that there's a lot of similarity it's
almost like they want to make
the existing sort of like western theory
to be almost like some
lockheed hubris when like really i think
you look at the tradition
there's lots of people like john
sturmill who like start from the point
of view of like the the fallibility of
the human being and that we're gonna be
wrong all the time and everything's
gonna be provisional
and you know and into like like and i
think even today in analytic philosophy
like there's really like
it's not fixated on some kind of like
weird cringey
like you know fight disclosing the
absolute universal truth to anything
it's like very much discourses about the
way in which we're
fallible the way in which like our our
reasoning our understanding of the world
is incomplete
constantly provisional so i don't know
that's
just my my added point i asked if that
was directly on point because i had a
response to matt that i think well and i
don't know where you ended up
you ended up well i'm at like the the
the truth function in language i guess
somewhere around there
i'm sorry my dildo comment threw you off
track victor but it had to get out there
then or it wouldn't have resonated
i'm sorry god damn you ruined it no you
didn't [ __ ]
discourse you son of a [ __ ] i thought
we were on the same side
we usually don't get into the weeds and
pick at each other
very specifically but i think we can
hear
because i can hear both sides of the
argument
i think maybe i'm wrong but matt i don't
think
you said a long time ago before dildos
before
browsers and before we got to the truth
function in language
that liberation is a moral
good and i don't see it that way at all
i think you can make a very material
good i said we have to think of it in
moral terms it may be moral good or it
may not be right but that's
implicitly claimed to be so in these
traditions
right so i don't think it is i think
liberation in terms of will you can give
a very materialist
analysis to this in saying that being
able to
see your will and acted in the world and
this is going to sound very nuchan
because it
is i've been reading a lot on each of
this week as it happens
but to see your will enacted in the
world
and to have power that's not
a moral claim at all it's more a claim
to
what the capacity of your action is
to change the circumstances around you
and in that sense
liberation has nothing to do with
goodness liberation
is something that i want and by
extension i can say
that i think that would be morally
better for a a society to endorse that
but the first claim in itself is a
material one
okay sure i mean i would agree with that
in the sense that before it is that we
talk about whether or not freedom is
valuable
we'd have to define what we mean by
freedom right
and i think that's a very interesting
philosophical task and i think nietzsche
does a spectacular job of it amongst
others right
what i'm just attacking or not nearly
attacking is just observing
is that most critical theorists don't
even really go that far
right and this is one of the problems i
had with foucault right uh it's only
near the end of this life where foucault
even starts to talk about what kind of
freedom he wants and why
right uh usually the kind of supposition
a lot of these kirito theoretical
traditions is just that
engaging in these kinds of enterprises
will allow people to be more free
kind of in some sense that's never
really articulated
and the implicit expectation is that
this is a good thing
right and i agree that it is a good
thing i would just like more explication
as to why and i just like to follow up
and i think eric might like this point
actually
i actually think that being explicit
about these kinds of motivations and
these normative judgments
normative in the capital n sense right
big and normativity
not just morality right is actually a
very critical enterprise because it
forces you to reflect upon your own
presuppositions on this point
and i'll give an anecdote that derek
parfitt points out when um
jack prophet is a moral philosopher at
oxford he died now wrote a three volume
book called on what matters that's
interesting
uh but he says he was engaging with a
neoliberal economist right
and the neoliberal economist was there
with all these raps describing the world
and he said
i've made no judgments one way or
another about the rightness or wrongness
of this
uh this is the policy we should enact
and prophet said
you actually have made a judgment uh
your judgment is that we should want the
economy to grow
and not shrink and the economy was kind
of paused and was like
well that's just silly nobody would ever
possibly question that
right but it is you know a judgment that
he's making right he's making a judgment
that
a certain kind of economic organization
is preferable because it increases gdp
growth and
this is the kind of policy we should act
on that basis and profits kind of point
is that the critical attitude is to
actually bring to the fore what's
morally contentious here
and force you to explain yourself uh on
those terms
so let me ask a question then is
demanding
that critical theorists make their
moral claims explicit
to use their own language is that not an
authoritarian gesture you demanding that
i put
the moral reasons behind what i do into
propositional language that can be
inserted into some kind of hegemonic
discourse
and evaluated according to analytic
philosophical rules
which translation like white men in
oxford
is not just an authoritarian gesture
that you're asking me like if i'm if i'm
an oppressed individual and part of a
marginal marginalized identity
and i'm saying something needs to change
i'm not happy with the status quo
and you demand that i make explicit my
moral reasoning behind what i'm saying
i'd say [ __ ]
you go you can go [ __ ] yourself i'm
gonna do what i'm gonna do to free
myself and my community
and you can take your propositional
language and your representational
[ __ ] and you can
go [ __ ] yourself all the way to
cambridge i don't give a [ __ ]
isn't that can i just say that like
that's a question okay
i'm not talking about activist movements
or everything
so activists do not enact morality
morality only takes place in theoretical
discourse hold on hold on no no no no
i think i think that i think you're
really strong manning there eric because
quite frankly i'm clearly not talking
about
and i'm asking a question i'm not making
any claims yeah but no
we're talking about critical theorists
who are engaged in a philosophy critical
people never make claims right
and if you're a critical theorist who's
engaging in a philosophical enterprise
first and foremost
then naturally the expectation is going
to be that other philosophers and people
engage in theory
are going to criticize you and ask you
to be explicit about the presuppositions
underpinning your own work
that's a big point is to change the
world philosophers have interpreted it
the point is to change the world
that's in critical theory we're not
engaged when we're talking about
morality and ethics
we're talking about behavior right what
does ethics mean
it means how to live well not how to
think well
not how to know how to philosophize in a
white tower
we don't need to talk about eric if
you're in the ambition is to change the
world you shouldn't do theory
you know i work for a [ __ ] ngo for a
long time i [ __ ] went
sorry i should have no theory behind
what i do i should just
run out my door and start smashing my
neighbor's windows i said if you do
if you are engaging in a theory and
you're offering a philosophical argument
for your position
as one does if you're a critical
theorist then you're opening yourself to
being judged on the basis of whether or
not
your philosophy rests on certain
presuppositions and you can be asked to
help
be held accountable on that basis if i'm
an activist who basically just says
you're depositing a metaphysical
i'm cutting all this off in the audio
everyone's been cut off
victor okay thank you talk about
authoritarian i would say that eric i
i do not think that matt i think you're
being a bit strong any there i don't
think that the claim here is that um
you know i asked the question i didn't
straw man i didn't make any claims
i just okay fine the implicit the
implicit okay the question
okay you're saying no and i respect well
then well then okay yeah okay well then
the answer would obviously be no i think
because it's not about like forcing
anybody
i think that well a proper response to
your question then would be
no no it's not about forcing people to
do certain things
it's about saying that if they're gonna
do theory if they're gonna write
like political theory then it's okay to
point out to be like actually there's a
lot of implicit moral claims here and
like your argument's kind of weak
because of that because you're not
actually saying
so it's about pointing into it it's
about criticizing a type of a form of
theory a form of argumentation
it's not about like saying you have to
do something else but it's more about me
being like
well i'm not gonna let you hide behind
you're like well you know we're we're
we're not gonna like make these claims
because they're contaminated with like
whatever western rationalism like no no
but like let's get away from that like
what are the underlying claims behind
your your crypto normative statements
and let's get
it's about being open to that criticism
that's all it's not about forcing people
to do something if you want
keep doing your shitty like unstated
like you know theories that don't have
like like like
transparently uh that's obviously i'm
fired
you guys are saying that theory and
practice are miles away from each other
and i'm saying in critical theory is
about
praxis about the way that theory leads
to practice
that you cannot do without thinking and
you cannot think
without leading well i agree we're
saying that there's two there's a
difference in
the things that different people do
which is a really common sense idea i'm
not gonna go talk to martin luther king
and be like sorry i'm okay you know
we really have to unpack why liberation
is important before we actually try to
engage in these liberation movements
so let's sit down and let's theorize on
this no you know he's an activist and
that's what he does
if you're dr cornell west though and you
lay out a tract saying
these are the philosophical
justifications for that the expectation
is a little bit different because now
you're making an argument
to a theoretical audience and you can be
held accountable on that basis
i happen to agree with cornell west and
i happen to agree with mlk
but they're doing different things right
so if you're a postcolonial theorist
uh who's making arguments that based on
implicit normative assumptions
i don't think there's anything wrong or
authoritarian was saying there's
implicit moral assumptions here i want
you to be clear about that
right uh if you're a postcolonial
activist uh in a tyrannical country
then you don't and you don't have time
for that then that's fine you know
nobody in their right mind is gonna be
coming and picking on you
being like you know [ __ ] before you
blow up that prison
uh or go attack that military depot you
know we really have to settle these
philosophical issues
well matt you're still just drawing a
huge distinction between these two and
saying
like this is the job of all these people
you're telling them how to write still
he's an activist as if he did yeah but
that's never
say anything isn't this super basic
though that's what we do pills if we're
not gonna sit there and say
your argument has problems with it this
is how i think your argument can be
better
then there's really no point in doing
theory right no that's the way that you
do this theory
but didn't we all talk on the grad
school episode right about like the
being open to critique and like the
process of getting your work read by
by other people and like like are you
saying that like you know if your
supervisor or someone or like some
some person is like well i think that
claim like there's an implicit claim
here like are you just gonna be like
well that's just the way i do theory so
like i'm not gonna
i don't know i mean i don't know i mean
those are two different scenarios i mean
when you're in a discussion like the one
we're in now
then i will defend my premises in a
different way than if i were writing a
book on it and i won't write a book on
it but if i were to
i wouldn't want to be like oh by the way
to all the matt mcmanusses out here
here's my four claims and i'm going to
put in a propositional
logic so i can lead to the conclusion
i would never want to write like that
but he's expecting that that be said i
don't think he's like you have to
also he said foucault has to give his
ethical reasons before
not not not that just clear just cl just
like
what's the worst i am pretty open to the
critique that i'm not
separating theory from practice enough
i'm not separating intellectual activity
from
activist activity but i just disagree
with that i think
theory should be geared towards action
and that's the point that's how it
cashes out if we sit around arguing
about morality forever
then we never get each other we never
get anywhere and that's why people think
moral theory
is not really worth the time people are
putting into it
because it's a careerist thing right we
write books
we publish articles we try to climb the
ranks and we try to get a good job
and that's fine but it doesn't really
get to the core
of what ethics is all about which is
again living well
okay but it's not about thinking you
could say the same about any theoretical
activity then i mean i could sit there
and say of course i would
if someone came up to me and said
evolution i would say what the [ __ ] is
your evidence did you go out into the
world and look at it yes he did darwin
sailed around the [ __ ] world and did
everything that needed to be done
okay but then come up with this theory
then what's the argument though eric i
mean if your argument is we shouldn't
just be sitting here theorizing all day
we should go out and change the world
that applies to every kind of theory you
know you could sit there and say to co
stop writing these goddamn books about
prison uh actually go out there and
advocate for prison reform you know
don't [ __ ] be dropping acid
and then decide to write you know your
history of sexuality and you know
arizona desert you know go out there and
start [ __ ] trying to change the san
francisco sex scene
you know this apply if your attitude is
kind of an anti-theorist
one you know we all feel like that at
some point i'm not trying to be
anti-intellectual about it i don't think
any of us can would deny that we
sometimes think like this is all
pointless let's make it gramscian idea
of the organic intellectual is somebody
who goes out to the margins and
advocates for them
and uses their powers to change the
world
and that's the point yeah and i think
that we should do that i mean that's
kind of what we're doing here but it's
just
to go back to pills going around
demanding people say accusing people of
making normative claims
and telling them that they should make
their premises more explicit
is a certain view of how
yeah it's a certain critique and i'm
open to it yeah i don't separate theory
from practice
quite so much but i disagree with that
critique i think it is
based on a certain moral view of moral
theory
that i just does not jive both what i do
so pills i was thinking maybe because i
heard um
either eric or matt say something about
like you know i think all of us
like care about and i feel like or all
of us occasionally think like what's the
point of what we're doing here
and i'm thinking about and i'm thinking
about pills as probably being the one
who who most often thinks like this is
all
uh pointless because i saw you on um
epoch's
uh stream and i know you were making
some interesting claims about politics
there i don't know i feel like they're
relevant to what we're talking about
maybe i'm putting you too much on the
spot here but
you are making some claims about like
that in some ways like this kind of
action of like going
going out and you know doing anything is
kind of pointless like you have to have
to like live your politics in a certain
way i don't know
if you don't want to answer i was making
a very simple
point there and i can make it again is
that
the things that you have power over this
is back to an earlier point that we
met and i were debating over the things
that you have power over are not
what other people do and how other
people write and how they should write
that the only thing you have power over
is
your immediate relationships and then
what you
create so don't criticize unless you're
creating matt i know you are a
creator you're busy at all at all hours
of the day making stuff
but i i get just like eric is getting
antagonized by this i get really
antagonized by
other people telling other people how
they should be writing
and i know that's not ultimately we're
trying to do you're saying i want this
to be clear
the whole doctrine could be clearer and
then we'd all be in a better place
but i think that's a kind of an
obnoxious
articulation of what you're hoping to
get at let me be clear because look
ultimately i don't know
it's not a belief it's not right belief
that changes the world it's not your
orthodoxy and it's not even the best
ideas are the most clearly
stated beliefs that change anything it's
only power
that has ever changed anything and you
can rearrange your ideas
into the best configuration on the
sinking ship but ultimately that's your
aesthetic decision i don't know why you
two thought i was directing this at you
no you directed it at fuco which is even
worse because he's way smarter than us
well yeah that's it
that's why i chose these people right
pacoa marks and all that stuff right
like
i had no idea that you two would take
this so personally right and
it's not like i [ __ ] sit there i
don't take [ __ ] personally man
okay well getting being antagonized it's
different than taking it
let me put it that way if we need to be
like male about this we can you know we
don't have feelings you know we haven't
you know but let me just put this i love
foucault at mercs
right i think they're brilliant figures
they offer incredible descriptions of
power capital you know you name it and i
completely agree with eric that these
are
vital theoretical enterprises to engage
in right
my critique is a pretty modest one in
some ways it's just like look if there
are normative reasons why we should be
engaged in critique or description
capital n normative to use an error like
kind of term then let's just be clear
about that and that's helpful
i'm not saying everyone's going to be
able to do it because none of us have a
million years i'm just saying it's
useful when that's done
and it's worth noting that vocode did do
that at the end of the life his life in
care of the self and other books right
he's trying to
criticize for being a liberal or
something well you know he talks about
kant and he says you know i was
committed to this ethics of
self-creation
al-anichi right this is why i talked
about some kinds of power being good and
some
productive and some being bad because
you know people should be empowered to
engage with this nephew and
self-creation
i find that pretty inspiring right and
knowing that helps it become
makes it the rest of his work and what
he's aiming for clearer to me
right just as you know when i sit there
i'm like okay marx is committed to this
idea
of uh the uh
universal freedom and equality for all
that's his kind of end goal
that makes things clearer for me as well
you know and then i can also evaluate it
more easily that's all i'm getting at
yeah i would just say don't don't
mistake my passionately delivering my
points
as me being upset i'm just saying
when we are talking about morality we're
also talking about
people who are in like current
situations
where there are massive imbalances in
power relations
and they do feel that there's a certain
urgency yeah and the idea of like
slowing down all the time when i
when i say like you know go [ __ ]
yourself take your argument back to
harvard or whatever
i'm saying there are certain yeah
there are certain situations that have a
certain amount of urgency
and the idea of always like trying to
translate
the world into theoretical terms or into
propositional
explicit terms whatever you want to call
them is kind of going against that
urgency and we need to realize that
there are people suffering now
it's not that's not a controversial
point and that
morality does have a certain urgency to
it and i think
that the sorts of logical arguments
that maybe like consequentialist
utilitarians make
do not have a certain urgency to them
they have a kind of air of like we have
all the time in the world to figure this
out so let's get down to the nuts and
bolts of it
and and and then that sort of says okay
well then we can separate theory from
practice
in a big way and i think the academia
does do that
but i what i just wanted to say was that
we shouldn't do that that there is an
internal relation between theory and
practice there's a
mutual relationship as a back and forth
relationship one feeds into the other
and i just want to play a little bit of
devil's advocate with those ideas about
about making good stuff explicit your
underlying moral arguments i mean if you
want to take a [ __ ] on like the
pretension of analytic moral
philosophers
if that's all you wanted to do i was
always happy to do that i would
love to do that because i agree with you
right like i told you
i referenced very perfectly charitably
this guy had 23 years to write this
three volume book
23 years where he did nothing else but
work on it and a lot of it's dense and
opaque and i have really no use for it
in my practical life and
the whole time i was reading it i had
exactly the same thoughts you did right
like this is all very theoretically
interesting
i'm not sure how this is actually going
to help me solve a single [ __ ] real
moral dilemma
that's me and myself and there is
definitely a privilege in being able to
engage in that kind of moral
philosophizing as there isn't any kind
of theoretical activity right
so if you want to talk about that sure
we can [ __ ] go discuss it till the
[ __ ] cows come home
right but i mean i i just think that
that gets at the heart of what we're
talking about when we're talking about
moral reasoning
morality and ethics and what's right and
what's wrong
i mean i think that should be at the
center of the conversation
and not the other things we're talking
about which is
you know how do we separate theory from
practice how do we make
proper moral arguments that are
logically consistent
i think those are important because i do
believe there's a certain logic
to everything that happens but i mean to
sit down and say we need to figure this
out
before we can act upon it is also
problematic
all right now we are getting to we are
shifting gears to
why we can't make moral arguments and
the reason of course
is the greatest critic of all time of
moralizing mr friedrich
nitch this will be a little bit of a
follow-up of
our episode on nietzsche but we never
got into the fact value distinction
in there so the problem with making
normative claims
generally speaking anytime after
nietzsche
is he says all of this is
making value distinctions these value
distinctions come from
a particular place in history where
someone is making a power play more or
less
so anytime you make a moral argument
there's a
first of all it's unchained from the sun
as he says
so it's just almost an arbitrary thing
to say
and probably implicit in there you're
making a power play and the
the nichianization of the left or vice
versa which is a chapter from an allen
bloombook
but the i think a reason that a lot a
lot of the
critical theory left does not appeal to
moral arguments and instead appeals to
arguments of power is because of this
uptake of nietzsche
that you can't really say what's
right and wrong or at least you can't
make arguments
on those grounds so i want to throw it
out there
if everything is value if everything is
the thing that you give it
like humans people societies give things
value
they don't have intrinsic value or a
historical value if everything is part
of history
then how do you go on to make moral
claims and
appeal to the fact that you think that
other people should
be making moral claims
is it right for me to make a vodka soda
right now is it right for me to ask for
time for that
you don't you shouldn't be asking you
should be expressing your will to power
i
will make a vodka soda right now and i
will be back in five minutes
and you can always [ __ ] yourself how
long does it taste
i'll be back in two minutes two minutes
all right i'm gonna tell you okay well i
can
can you express that try to answer like
all right start getting at an answer to
that by sort of
saying that i mean i guess i'm also
skeptical i kind of think that nietzsche
is also a little bit of a crypto
normativist and cert in a certain sense
in the sense that i think there is a lot
i mean i guess he's inconsistent on
depending on what you read by him but
i mean he does talk about health right
and like the
like the health and or sickness of the
human being
and presumably that has normative
implications
it's like if if an animal is sick or not
nature's not a crypto normativist in
that sense though he's an express
normativist he says that health health
is the value of anything that's alive
right okay okay so then so then he's not
a crypto normativist i suppose
um the question is if he's a crypto
moralist because i
i've heard that claim before and i kind
of just i adamantly disagree with it
right i mean i i think i think what
what what happened after nietzsche was
was something that
matt and victor have pointed out is that
there's no more universal claims about
ethics or morality that everything is
particular
i mean that's that's one of the ways to
sort of defend yourself
from i don't know i guess getting on the
wrong side of what nietzsche was saying
is that you have to you have to
particularize everything
to certain so when when matt asks for
instance whether it's okay right now
to make a vodka soda that's a very
different
thing from was it okay half an hour ago
to make one was it okay in an hour
if i were in zimbabwe would have been
okay i'm gonna make one too goddamn
everything becomes a kind of
particularistic claim
after one second and so now make sure if
you're listening you send the check okay
ew plastic no victor victor's drinking
real vodka oh my god
that that looks like a russian one to
our listeners we don't usually record on
friday so
we're not always drinking when we do the
podcast but as it is
friday at 5 45 i think this is uh
about to get a little bit more spicy
yeah i'm gonna go get one too
is it is it right i don't give a [ __ ] i
can tell you from having tried mine now
that it is right
it's both right and good and
aesthetically sublime so
very nice and refreshing yeah i mean i
mean my my approach is is that yeah like
it
it leads to a kind of particularism
because
universalistic claims are actually just
metaphors that's what
like and they're they're linguistically
oriented right truth is a mobile army of
metaphors
metonymies and anthropomorphisms i think
i think part of that is that
we are the creature who's imagined that
we've built this edifice of knowledge
but really it's built on shifting sands
and therefore it's going to be it's
going to be different it's built
the foundations itself are rotten and
we're just fooling ourselves if we think
these are universal
moral claims and so we have to back up
and say okay what do we actually mean
by universal do we mean like all places
all times do we mean like a priori like
necessary universal
logically sound or do we mean just
something more like like
in general that that's what universal
tends to mean from like prospero says
you know
we are such stuff as dreams are made of
you know but then the nietzschean claim
here is a little bit more than there are
no universals it's saying that the posit
the original position that appeals
to universals is a position of
not being able to create of trying to
make people play by your rules
so that you have a better chance at the
game so in that sense it's a power play
well i'm gonna do my little spiel on
this and say uh actually
i'm sure you'll be surprised to hear
this that i don't think there is
actually a definitive way
of rebutting the niche and claim right
um if you tend to believe that morality
needs to be grounded in something like
ontology uh you know that mores come
from a description of how things
are and not from human subjectivity with
all the kind of difficulties that that's
entailed
then you're probably not going to end up
getting that right
uh i think that's you know at the core
of his kind of insight and the core of
the kind of modernist insight about
normativity more generally
right uh the only argument that i can
claim for the existence of morality
uh is one that's put forward by ronald
dworkin uh he has a very good paper
called
a truth and objectivity you better
believe it uh where he kind of makes
this argument which is that
uh we can be external skeptics and
internal skeptics right
external skeptics uh basically hold that
we can't ground our moral views
uh about in any kind of external truth
uh to human subjectivity right uh and he
says there's really no way of rebutting
this person
right you need to have a very fully
worked out ontological theory that
grounds morality
we're not gonna get that right uh but he
says that if you it's actually very
difficult to be what it calls an
internal skeptic
which is basically to act as if you do
hold
that certain things are true morally
right and i think that he's right about
this i mean if you think about
the kind of way we make value judgments
about our life the vocabularies that we
use even anthropologically
most of them express at least a kind of
certainty that there's something that's
worthwhile
about human life and in existence and
it's our job to figure out what that is
i've never heard that argument before
but i'm actually extremely
sympathetic to it which is i don't don't
appeal
to the historical because that's a
stupid thing to do
but if you're talking to someone and
they just say i'm gonna do what i want
because there is what you're calling the
internal
if they're saying there's no a
historical so i'm gonna do whatever i
want then that person's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and
they're not gonna have any friends and
you're not gonna wanna talk to them so
not just that
bernard williams wrote a really good
book called morality where he actually
at
he wrote it was really open with a
really interesting essay where he says
could we actually be a consistent
nihilist
like hold to nihilism the whole way
through and the conclusion you reached
is you could
you know you could be a consistent
nihilist and live by those principles
uh but it would be a really warped
[ __ ] up individual that would bear no
individual like resemblance to anything
that we call a human being
uh because this is somebody who really
could not complain about anything could
it make any value judgments
probably couldn't even make aesthetic
judgments yeah really about things
we were talking about this while you
were getting a drink matt but nietzsche
is certainly
not anti-normative
but he's definitely a he's an a moralist
and i think a consistent
a moralist on this point yeah but you
can't act that way so i was expecting
this to be
i don't know do do you think we should
explain the fact value distinction for
the listeners
well i was well i actually was curious
what's how do you distinguish between
being a moralist versus a normativist
i mean i don't think you do i i
distinguished it earlier by saying like
normativism is is much broader than just
morality it goes into everything
whenever you
talk about what we should do how we
should do something you're making
normative claims like i said even
the scientific method when we're talking
about how we should best investigate
natural phenomena
because it's how how we should best do
that so when you're
a moralist is just a more specific
version of normativity yes but but then
how but how is the claim that like a
human being healthy
uh is is better than not how is that not
a moral claim
it isn't it could be a moral claim in a
way
because you're saying because you're
saying nietzsche's like fixation right
on like the health
of of of like the human um of the huma
of the human uh spirit
of like the human whatever it's called
like the um
uh i'm like no it is well just it's well
but okay sure but like so how is that
not immoral how is that not a moral
claim
there's no um in injunction as to
what your behavior should be
oh wait so all i don't know about that
also he's not is he saying something is
the difference between right and wrong
like when we're talking about morality
that's specifically what we're talking
about
and if it if you say it's implicit then
okay there's moralism there
but it but if he's not making it
explicit then you can't really
say that he's made a moral claim because
when i'm when i'm thinking about
like more more moral philosophy like i'm
thinking about like
being able to evaluate a certain state
of affairs to be like better than other
ones or whatever and it's like and then
you make like sort of decisions about
how you should act based on like your
judgment about
what the better or worse states of
affairs and it seems to me nietzsche is
saying that like a state where
the human spirit is healthiest or
whatever is like is like a better state
of affairs therefore that seems like a
moral claim to me
yeah because more like i i just have
this one thing is because what what
nietzsche like what nietzsche does
differently is
if you go back and read like moral
philosophy
which is all philosophy was there was
two kinds of philosophy moral philosophy
and natural philosophy and when you're
doing
moral philosophy or if you even look at
how the greeks did it right they had a
whole cosmology
like usually there's a kind of
metaphysical nucleus
whether it's plato's distinction between
like the realm of ideas and the realm of
things that reflect those ideas or
whether it's aristotle's you know
material form substance distinctions
like around that is
built a cosmology and then the human
world
is assumed to be a microcosm within that
macrocosm
and to say well if there's an order
built into the universe
then we can actually build a human
society that reflects
that order and that's the moral claim
behind it is that
human society needs to reflect the order
of the universe
and what nietzsche is doing is bringing
it more to a radical sort of
individualist perspective
is to say that actually the health of
your body and the health of your mind is
what's important
what's not important is this grand
system moral building where we say
society has to reflect some kind of
implicit cosmological order or some kind
of
nucleus of metaphysical distinctions
it's all about the person
and what other people think or how
society is organized
be damned and that like that's th that's
a shift to a different kind of morality
it's not
saying it's not i do think he's making
aesthetic judgments and this is where i
think the shift comes in
right uh so nietzsche i agree does
sometimes sound a bit like a relativist
and even a nihilist right but
uh at his head of most strident he hates
him
yeah exactly right yeah exactly so but
at his most stridently anti-niles that's
what i was going to say
he does tend to say that we still awaken
we'll make value judgments
there's no getting away from that right
and i think this relates back to us
talking about with
the impossibility of internal skepticism
right he's saying you know there's no
way we're going to not make
value judgments but we should recognize
at least to his mind that these are
aesthetic judgments
not moral in the sense that say eric was
talking about morality
in the sense that they flow from some
kind of deep metaphysical truths
about the way that the world should be
aesthetic judgments are what he calls
you know judgments of the nose
you know uh you happen to like slave
morality i happen to like you know
an aristocratic morality focused on the
will to power
and the creation of the ubermensch right
and he says that's all that we can
really understand
value judgments to be it's these
aesthetic evaluations and i think a lot
of people picked up on that i mean if
you look at uh somebody like wickenstein
and the tractatus philosophical
tractatious logical philosophicals he
says you know
ethics and aesthetics are one and the
same uh you can't really disconnect them
yeah even purse says ethics aesthetics
and logic are all just different
versions of
normative science where we study
normativity
victor is not satisfied with his
argument well no i just i i wanted to
try to clarify like
put it into slightly different terms
because i guess what i'm wondering is
is it really like is nietzsche just
rebelling against or or undermining
the the kind of ex like the thickness of
the kind of explanation that we have for
moral truths so like he's saying like
in fact we don't need this kind of like
thick cosmological explanation
of of to to ground morality and like i
fully agree with that and i think that
like so would someone like jon stewart
mill and so would like a lot of the
people that matt and i like in like the
liberal tradition like they're all
i think similar in that sense and that
they're making the same a similar kind
of moral argument
as nietzsche in in their rejection
that's actually one of my frustrations
that i was kind of getting at earlier
with
chris i just want to point out that he
used thick ground and frustration all
right and i'm trying to [ __ ] use
jesus you metaphysical dildo
yeah no i i think you're right i i i
don't think
i think that you're kind of reading
nietzsche at least differently than i am
both that and victor there because he's
not saying
let's do either or let's slave morality
and master morality are equivalent
he's saying slave morality is the only
force that can defeat
master morality whatever but master
morality in line with the will to power
is the way that life works and there's
nothing worse for him
than a condemnation of life by the
living
so the like it would be insane to think
that a living creature
could not want its own health only
priests do that priests are like the
tumor
of everything that exists because
they're the only thing that denies their
own
life so in that sense he's normative but
i would
say like i guess my understanding of
morality
is much less than what's good i think i
would call that ethics
i always think of morality in terms of
power like how do you tell other people
what they should
and should cut your rights you how do
you how do you determine actions
ethics is the doing one moral is the
right and wrong one
but i think but i also think that's the
reason there's a confusion here is
because i think like the anglo-american
tradition of philosophy
did sort of co-opt that word morality to
include
moral philosophy to include like
this much broader definition of just
like normativity so like i don't think
so i think you're right that like in the
old and i remember even when i was you
know in undergrad and wasn't familiar
with philosophy yet
i remember that word getting thrown
around and i was thinking about it in
the way that probably nietzsche thought
about it as like this kind of like
imposition of power like telling you
like what you're supposed to follow like
this more that you're supposed to like
follow and not
question when really like moral
philosophy means like any sort of study
of like of like being able to evaluate
something as being better or worse or
like prescriptive or not it's like all
of that is included in moral philosophy
i think
that's a lot victor because i think
that's really anything to do with
thoughts
reasoning anything to do with thought
reasoning
human beings living together that's all
moral philosophy
if you're going out and doing
experiments or reasoning about the way
the world
is then it's natural philosophy which is
what we call science now
and we make a huge distinction today
between science
and philosophy which is moral in
brackets
because we think everything that has to
do with human beings
and the humanities and the social
sciences is all moral philosophy
by 18th century standards and and before
that yeah
can i can i just quickly look before
matt you [ __ ] interrupted me before
with your dick jokes earlier and i
didn't even get to finish my thought
i didn't make a joke the joke was the
absence of the joke
you liar you [ __ ] you're just like the
crypto normativist with your crypto joke
that was obviously underlying there that
you refused to state
the president the absence of the joke
and to be pharaoh is a synthetic dick
joke not an actual dick joke
hey crypto crypto's good good all right
then they say uh
a crypto semiotician is is good for us
to discover if we find somebody who's a
crypto moralist we should uh
we should pay attention this is why i
should say i'm a little bit surprised
that you two are
angry about this claim that we should
make explicit our moral judgments
because one of the people i think it's
not a claim that's a moral
determination i also still haven't even
been able to make my point here
all right make a point and then
okay no go go now so like all i want to
say before about like
is my frustration i think with is with
this
this idea what right when we were
distinguishing between like the level of
explanation that you accept for
a moral claim right as being as eric put
it linked to a cosmology
i sometimes think that that's like with
a critical theory tradition is
still stuck in this idea that like the
anglo-american or whatever or a
rationalist school
is still trying to ground their morality
and something like that
and i think that's the thing that i
mostly get frustrated about is like
the distortion and kind of straw manning
that oh like all these analytic or
whatever
they're trying to ground in this like
broader and it's like no that's like not
what they're doing at all
uh they're doing something that's like
at a similar level of modesty as like
nietzsche saying that like the health of
the human spirit i mean
i'm not trying to equate them but i'm
just saying that like the level of
explanation that is accepted for saying
that one state of affairs is better than
another
is is not that much is not some grand
cosmology like
that that that sort of western like
rationalist hubris has been over for a
long time and i feel like the critical
tradition
pretends that it's still so active when
i don't think it is well i'm saying that
nietzsche is a vitalist i don't think
critical theorists are generally
speaking
vitalists or ever yeah that's true
that's true
yeah and i just want to say i think that
you're absolutely right about that
victor i mean if you think about it
the kind of surge of interest in meta
ethics that's appeared over the last 70
years
demonstrate that there's a huge amount
of anxiety about what can ground
moral claims or normative big n
normativity uh more generally right
uh and i mean there's a million
different kind of meta-ethical schools
out there everything from
the one i hold to which is a
quasi-cognitive
uh quasi-cognitive is moral realism
right to naturalism and whatever
but i did just want to say that one of
the things that i think is odd about
this
more general structure is there was a
little bit of pushback against
uh me and victor arguing that we should
make explicit the kind of normative
claims that underpin our descriptive
work
right let's just like pause on that
person you should get hit with a dildo
always but one of the things that i
think is interesting is that like
nietzsche was probably the
paramount critic in this respect because
i mean he saw
crypto normativity to use victor's terms
everywhere i remember he has this like
lampooning
uh caricature of cancer metaphysics
where he essentially says
all this is is a bunch of garbage that
can't invent it so he could get back to
the catechol comparative
that's what this is all about and we
should realize that and be overt about
that
um because you know the reason why he
wants to deny the world is in order to
make rey for faith
that's exactly why what he said in the
critique of pure reason i like when he
just calls kant
old kant yeah well not he said but it
was speaking
christian who just wanted to rationalize
christianity
yeah just replace god with reason yeah
but this is what i'm saying
you know nietzsche was pretty overt
about that he says you know let's make
you know let's put all our cards at the
table and say why it is that we
want these things from the perspective
of value and he was pretty overt about
that also where he'd say things like
i'm making a value judgment also it's an
aesthetic value judgment
and it's a judgment that i think that
the morality that we have right now this
kind of slave morality
that's the residue of christianity is
sick and we should get rid of it and
make way for our master morality instead
i'm laying my cards out on the table and
saying this is what we should do
which is what many moral philosophers
and many other natural philosophers for
that reason
for that in that respect don't actually
do as long as you know
that you're only making an aesthetic
judgment based on what you prefer
matt there's no there's no categorical
imperative that everyone should write
the way that you want them to write
there's no categorical imperative that
i'll say well
i can't i can't um i can't exactly
respond to the whole nietzsche part of
what you're saying but i can remain with
the
the normative thing and say well
maybe we're not as far away from a
cosmology as we
think we are contra victor but not
totally
because we are away from that quite a
bit who's we
right now i well let's say okay who is
this
just me for now so just me for now
don't worry i'm gonna say if if you are
okay saying like if i give it to you
that you can say
okay i'm going to demand not demand but
i'm going to request
that you make explicit your normative
assumptions that are behind your
arguments
that are so-called descriptive then i
could also just as well say well can you
please make explicit your ontological
assumptions that are behind your
morality
because a lot of again what
utilitarianism and consequentialism has
is it has a metaphysics it has an
epistemology
built into it which is often the case is
logical positivism
yeah that nothing exists except the
physical world
and the physical world is the thing we
can find out about and that brings us
back to the fact value distinction
so only facts pertain to
say what we were calling natural
philosophy and values are subjective and
that's what pertains to moral philosophy
and great we have so many all these nice
little clean binaries now
but what i'd say is that epistemological
assumption
that relates to ontology that says what
exists and what doesn't exist
what is physical and what we can touch
and what we can confirm
is true and what really just depends on
what people think and how people
deliberate and come to conclusions and
arrange things that has an ontology
built into it
that is really consequential for
our normative claims and what we think
about morality right like if we don't
think that relations are real things for
example if i don't think that the
mother-son relationship is a real thing
if it's all in my head
for example or the only way i can
confirm it is looking at my genes
for example then i can't make any moral
claims based on that because that is an
is relationship and not an ought
relationship because then i have to say
well how ought you treat your mother
well i can't base that on our genetics
but
again all of that is besides the point
because it's an ontology that's built
into the way
i moralize so really the cosmology
leading to a morality approach that the
ancient greeks took
is really just another version of what
these utilitarian consequentialists are
doing today by claiming that well
logical positivism is the only real
thing
and i disagree with them that only
science can make positive claims i can
make
positive moral claims as well but in the
end i'm still a positivist and there's
still a whole ontology built around that
idea
and and so the normativity is actually
subordinate
to that so you should actually be asking
people not to make their normative
claims explicit
but to make their metaphysical claims
explicit
all right so i just want to make it
clear then that
you're willing to grant our me and
victor's kind of nietzsche claim that
you make obvious your value judgments
if we're willing to grant your
heidigarian claim that we may clear our
ontological presupposition is that the
exchange that you have on offer
[Music]
i mean it's like a bit of a chicken and
egg situation with that but yeah
sure i like that okay i'll take it i'll
i'll take it i'll buy that deal
i i buy that too well yeah like
that's the thing though when we do make
our moral our normative premises
explicit we're in i mean
you're right i think he is right yeah we
end frame and we and we put them within
an implicit ontological framework and
then how do we get outside of that
ontological framework
well then we have to make our normative
claims clear that lead us to
hold those ontological claims valuable
and then again you just have an infinite
regress and then i have to make my
ontological claims and my normative
claims
and you just end up with an infinite
regress yeah no i i'm
i'm pretty sympathetic to that sorry i i
don't mean to interrupt i'll let you
finish your point but uh there was a lot
of terminology in there can you just
re-articulate what he said first
yeah so i think i mean okay so this is
how i'm hearing it which is
that like if you're gonna talk about if
you're gonna make some sort of claim
about like what is a better or worse
state of affairs to put like a normative
claim very simply
like you have to maybe make some kind of
metaphysical or ontological claim about
like
and i guess to put it simply like what
is the human being for example like like
what is the nature of the world or like
what is the nature of what we can know
that's more of an epistemological claim
i suppose
but like the reason i'm sympathetic to
it is because i think and i don't know
if i'll be able to explain this
succinctly right now
but a lot of my own like sympathy for
the kinds of sort of
incomplete um normative claims that i'm
willing to make
um are based on like my ontology of like
human fallibility as being like stuck in
kind of incomplete knowledge
but like we notice similarities in the
ways
um that human beings are and like a lot
of that's informed by lacanian
psychoanalysis or like mira laponte and
phenomenology like
just the way that the situatedness of
the human being
which leads us to i don't know if this
is going to get too abstract but
leads us to sort of have contingent like
so there's a there's a there's
a structure that i think you can
identify in lacanian psychoanalysis or
or meroloponte and phenomenology that
that is consistent across human beings
that then gets filled in with with
content that is contingent
um but still i think you can make you
can you can use that platform to make
certain kinds of normative claims which
i think eric is saying that like
that it's bet we should be talking about
that those kinds of like
the ontological grounding which is a
difficult thing but i think i think he's
right that it's it's worth
it's worth clarifying for me it is so
informed by
human fallibility the incompleteness of
knowledge like like our uncertainty but
i still think that that leads to
um the possibility to make certain kinds
of claims i don't know if any of that
made sense sometimes it does
i think this is exactly what dwarkin is
arguing about when he thinks when he
talks about external
internal skepticism uh you know his kind
of argument is that look
we are never going to have a full-blown
ontological account of where our value
judgments come from
uh that actually explains some kind of
connection between the world that's
external to us
how it is that all those cosmologies
operate where morality comes from etc
it's not going to happen right uh i
think though that he fundamentally
accepts the point made by
kent and i think in a much more vitrolic
way nietzsche that look you know
regardless of that fact you know the
fact that we're wrapped in human
subjectivity which is inevitably partial
finite
uh and we're going to make value
judgments so we should try to
make sense of where those value
judgments come from and see if we can
give them a little bit of a fine tuning
now there's a lot of argument about what
that fine-tuning entails but i think we
can all agree that it's a useful
enterprise to do that
or if you want to be a critical theorist
to at least try to expose
where it is that the value judgments we
happen to make are
to bring them to the surface so that we
can more critically analyze them
right i think we'd all agree on that
well now we've gone
all the way through the ontology of the
greeks
the moralism of the british slash
enlightenment rationalists all the way
through nietzsche
and the thing that we've determined at
the end of the day is don't be an
[ __ ]
is that is that i was going to say
exactly the same thing with my joke at
the end
why the [ __ ] did you know do that i was
going to say like the one moral truth is
don't be an [ __ ]
god damn it yeah i mean
i mean const morality is based on his
distinction between a priori and a
posteriori
and that's that's all you can say about
it because duties have to be universal
and necessary
and then the way you actually like
practice
those things they come out in very
different ways but they're guided by
that and that's
that's const epistemology whereas
someone like uh
i don't know what one of our patrons
probably wants to hear about um
wants to hear about uh um
levynos levynos makes ethics
yeah the first thing like the first
philosophy
and then and then maybe like other kinds
of philosophy follow that
so it's kind of a reversal of kant but
they did realize right away that kant
had made a gap
he made a gap between theory and
practice pure reason and practical
reason
and he tried to sort of patch that up
with
the critique of judgment and a lot of
people weren't convinced by that
sort of thing and i don't even think
kant was really satisfied with it
in the end but it really can't never had
a wife or anything so was he really
satisfied
in any sense you know what i mean what
are you saying that
you need a wife to be happy well i mean
having a sexual partner would be useful
you know for a certain way are you
saying that sexual partners are only
good for their utility okay well in 18
cent in 18th century germany
you're the worst moralist i've ever
heard in 18th century germany i'm pretty
sure i suppose that oh my god
uh koenigsberg he would need a wife in
order to engage in those kinds of
i heard he was a partier though he
probably just got like a lot a lot of
like side uh
yeah we gotta say not not just don't be
an [ __ ] but also don't be a priest
i like that i like that tweet today
pills could you expand on that tweet uh
like
i was i i liked it a lot though i pre i
agree with that i'm like
with with what i think the like um
sentiment is behind it but maybe you
could say more about that yeah we're
gonna do that on a different day
uh i was i was i was reading zarathustra
the priesthood
well i think i mean i like you know just
on that
like priest i think maybe some of the
things that i find uh
i mean i like i find the people the most
unpalatable when i think they're being
kind of priests
and i think there's lots of different
examples on lots of different sides
that's why you don't like daddy yeah i
don't like daddy daddy's a priest for
sure
for sure right now yeah they have a lot
of names the injunctives the gatekeepers
grammarians basically anyone who
purports to speak on behalf of the
universal in order to
blood sacrifice particularity i mean a
priesthood
yeah like a small group of people who
who just dictate what's good
i mean cancel culture some of it is
priestly which is a good move i mean
it's a it's a good move
yeah nietzsche had respect for it he
said that the
how the hell did judeo-christianity
conquer the greatest civilizations
that have ever existed i thought this
went well though i mean it was
definitely spicy i had fun
eric likes screaming on behalf of like
the third world of me likes pounding my
fist and like
victor being like can i say something
are you trying to get my [ __ ] word in
with you you're you're a [ __ ] tyrant
over there matt
oh [ __ ] well i was just like this is the
guy that makes the most moral arguments
and he's just
very immoral based on the amount of
space he takes up
guys we're doing gram sheet in a few
days it looks like that
it looks that way he's winning the vote
for our our patron
episode but for now oh is that on monday
we need to
escape our apartments for the first time
in months
yeah we're going to finally get to see
eric are you coming
uh that's yet to be determined
restrictions have been lifted so we're
going to go uh visit the green space
so from me pills
yeah later i live on university avenue
see you later guys we're gonna say
thanks for all coming out be good
everybody don't be an astronaut don't be
a priest amen
adios amen to not being a priest okay
[Music]
you